well hi so i'm uh here with uh professor uh dr james maffey who's uh the author of a book we reviewed a long time ago that I probably should have done this back when I read it two or three years back. So it'd be a little fresher on my mind. But Aztec Philosophy, which is interesting. So you have,
你好，我今天和詹姆斯·马菲（James Maffey）教授在一起，他是我们很久以前评论过的一本书的作者。我本应该在两三年前读完那本书时就做这件事，这样我的记忆会更清晰一些。那本书是《阿兹特克哲学》（Aztec Philosophy），非常有趣。所以，
and I was wanting to bring my copy to show it off, but I'm noticing it's on the shelf right behind you with the cover visible. So I'm glad that we can see it. And I'd love to hear uh some of your your your book like one of the reasons i was so like interested by it is like i was a comparative religion guy at swanee and then like now i'm more of a jungian leaning therapist i do some more i think the newer neurology is actually
我本来想带上我的那本展示一下，但我注意到它就在你身后的书架上，封面清晰可见。所以我很高兴我们能看到它。我很想听听关于你这本书的一些内容。我之所以对它如此感兴趣，是因为我在斯瓦尼（Sewanee）大学时是研究比较宗教学的，而现在我更倾向于成为一名荣格派治疗师。我认为新的神经学实际上
validating the older yungian phenomenology in a way that we probably won't rewind the clock and give anybody the credit they deserve but um so i'm always into that stuff and i love mythology and um but aztec mythology was always kind of hard for me to intuitively get because there were so many like cultural distinctions you know some of that regional some of that economic that they just look different and that affects culture differently and reading your book it's like oh that's it like this is the thing that makes the art make sense this is the thing that makes the ritual make sense this is the thing that makes economy make sense um so the title like when you named it aztec philosophy was that
正在以某种方式验证古老的荣格现象学，虽然我们可能不会倒转时钟去给予任何人他们应得的赞誉，但我一直对这些东西很感兴趣，我也热爱神话。但是，阿兹特克神话对我来说一直很难直观地理解，因为有太多的文化差异，你知道，有些是区域性的，有些是经济性的，它们看起来不同，这也会以不同的方式影响文化。读了你的书，我恍然大悟，原来这就是让艺术变得合理、让仪式变得合理、让经济变得合理的东西。所以，当你给它命名为《阿兹特克哲学》时，
kind of a practical thing and that you were trained in philosophy and wanted to publish there or uh because it more of is kind of about metaphysics almost or a cultural kind of a practical thing and that you were trained in philosophy and wanted to publish there or because it more of is kind of about metaphysics almost or a cultural kind of assumption what was can you tell us about your process and writing that and conceiving of the book um i mean the book is about metaphysics but metaphysics is a chapter of philosophy but the book didn't get the title aztec Metaphysics because the publisher thought no one would read it. So that's why I've had the broader title. And that's why in the introduction, I make it clear that the book is addressing specifically the metaphysics and that in a subsequent book, I'll address the ethics. Well, a lot of some people may not be familiar a ton you know with all of aztec culture
这是一种实际的考虑吗？因为你受过哲学训练，想在那里出版，还是因为它更多是关于形而上学，或者是一种文化上的假设？你能告诉我们你写作和构思这本书的过程吗？我的意思是，这本书是关于形而上学的，但形而上学是哲学的一个分支，不过这本书没有被命名为《阿兹特克形而上学》，因为出版商认为没人会读。这就是为什么我用了更宽泛的标题。这也是为什么在导言中，我明确指出这本书专门探讨形而上学，而在下一本书中，我将探讨伦理学。好吧，有些人可能对阿兹特克文化不太熟悉，
so i guess and correct me where i'm wrong here because most of the stuff i've read about you know it's not i may be mispronouncing something or i may not grasp it perfectly but you know the aztec is actually the military you know imperial class of the of an empire we use it to refer to a whole civilization but the mexico and the nahua are going to be am i saying this correctly uh yeah it should be machica machica okay nahua yeah so and could you tell us a little bit about that cultural group just the structure of the empire before you get into you know the uh the philosophy part um well the aztec is a word that was uh given it's a european no word i mean it's not it's a not what derived not what is the language of the aztec or the mexica or more broadly there's a
所以我猜——如果我说错了请纠正我——因为我读过的大部分资料，我可能发音不准，或者理解得不够透彻，但你知道，“阿兹特克”实际上是一个帝国的军事帝国阶层，我们用它来指代整个文明，但“墨西加”（Mexica）和“纳瓦”（Nahua）才是……我这样说对吗？是的，应该是“墨西加”。好的，纳瓦。那么，你能给我们介绍一下那个文化群体吗？在进入哲学部分之前，先介绍一下帝国的结构。嗯，“阿兹特克”这个词是欧洲人给的，它不是纳瓦特尔语（Nahuatl）词汇。纳瓦特尔语是阿兹特克人或墨西加人的语言，或者更广泛地说，有一个
whole ethnic group who are not what speakers and they are collectively referred to as the Nahwas or the Nahwas. And a German named von Humboldt decided to name them the Aztecs because they had mythically originated in a place called Aztlan, which is mythically northwest Mexico, Southwest USA. And that is, in fact, where the people who we call the Aztecs, but they're properly the Mexica, they originated from. They and a lot of other Nahuatl speakers migrated down from that area of the Southwest US, Northwest Mexico in the 14th century. The language itself, Nahuatl, is part of what linguists call the Uto-Aztecan language. It's related to Luiseno, Cahuilla, Ute, Paiute, Comanche, and Hopi.
庞大的族群都是纳瓦特尔语使用者，他们被统称为“纳瓦人”（Nahwas）。一位名叫冯·洪堡（von Humboldt）的德国人决定称他们为“阿兹特克人”，因为他们神话般地起源于一个叫阿兹特兰（Aztlan）的地方，神话中位于墨西哥西北部或美国西南部。事实上，我们称之为阿兹特克人（但他们正确称呼是墨西加人）的人确实起源于那里。他们和许多其他纳瓦特尔语使用者在14世纪从美国西南部、墨西哥西北部地区迁徙下来。纳瓦特尔语本身属于语言学家所说的“犹他-阿兹特克语系”（Uto-Aztecan）。它与路易塞诺语（Luiseno）、卡威拉语（Cahuilla）、尤特语（Ute）、派尤特语（Paiute）、科曼奇语（Comanche）和霍皮语（Hopi）有关。
So there's a whole language group there. And within Mexico, it's related to Huichol and Cora as well, and all the way down to San Salvador, El Salvador, the Pipil, which is an Uto-Aztecan language. So Nahua, that language became the lingua franca of the Mexica or the Aztec Empire. So the Mexica were one specific group who followed a guy named Tenocha. And their capital city on the island was called Tenochtitlan after him. But they were not the only Nahua speakers. So as I said, scholars refer to this whole sort of cultural linguistic group of people as the Nahw speakers from around the Great Basin
所以那里有一个完整的语系。在墨西哥境内，它也与维乔尔语（Huichol）和科拉语（Cora）有关，一直延伸到萨尔瓦多的皮皮尔语（Pipil），那也是一种犹他-阿兹特克语言。所以纳瓦特尔语成为了墨西加帝国或阿兹特克帝国的通用语。墨西加人是追随一个叫特诺查（Tenocha）的人的特定群体。他们在岛上的首都以他的名字命名为特诺奇蒂特兰（Tenochtitlan）。但他们并不是唯一的纳瓦特尔语使用者。正如我所说，学者们将这一整类文化语言群体称为纳瓦特尔语使用者，他们来自大盆地
and the highlands of Mexico, that lake area, where like one to two million people, Nahua speakers lived. So the Aztecs weren't just, they were one of many groups who were Nahua speakers. They happened to be a foreign part of what's called the Triple Alliance with two other city states um but yeah and so a lot of the aztec culture that people are familiar with is probably like the what we would imagine of like human sacrifice festivals pyramids um and a lot of that stuff i think seems kind of alien until you understand some cultural assumptions because i was always
和墨西哥高地，那个湖泊地区，大约有一到两百万人是纳瓦特尔语使用者。所以阿兹特克人不仅仅是他们，他们只是众多纳瓦特尔语使用者群体中的一个。他们恰好是所谓的“三方同盟”中与另外两个城邦结盟的一部分。但是，是的，人们熟悉的许多阿兹特克文化可能就是我们想象中的那种人祭、节日、金字塔，很多东西在理解一些文化假设之前似乎显得很怪异，因为我总是
like reading trying to make those make sense and some of the theories i just didn't really find plausible at all like there was somebody you know in the 70s that wrote a paper was like well they just didn't have a lot of meat right they kind of had to eat people and it was like well yeah i don't know i mean there's ducks there's other stuff you know there there were some there were some um other people that were like well you know the religion was so strong that the people who were getting captured in the flower wars really wanted to be sacrificed they thought it was great yet they did tend to side with cortez and say we don't like the aztecs so i had a hard time kind of buying that but i think your book makes a lot of the like assumptions that seem bizarre to us moderns or people that are coming from a more western background
在阅读时试图理解这些，而有些理论我根本觉得不可信。比如70年代有人写了一篇论文说，他们只是因为肉类不足，所以不得不吃人。我就想，好吧，我不确定，我的意思是，那里有鸭子，还有其他东西。你知道，还有一些人说，宗教力量太强大了，那些在“花之战”（Flower Wars）中被俘的人真的想被献祭，他们认为这很棒。然而，他们确实倾向于站在科尔特斯（Cortez）一边，说我们不喜欢阿兹特克人。所以我很难相信那种说法。但我认为你的书让很多对我们现代人或有西方背景的人来说显得离奇的假设
make a ton of sense that this concept of Teot is like this energy that is constantly sort of roiling and devouring and sustaining itself and that everything that the Aztecs are doing is a reenactment of that sort of implicit assumption about the way the universe works. I mean you call it being on slippery earth.
变得非常合理。这个“特奥特”（Teot）的概念就像是一种不断翻腾、吞噬并维持自身的能量，阿兹特克人所做的一切都是对宇宙运作方式这种隐含假设的重演。我的意思是，你称之为“在湿滑的土地上”。
We're always trying to you know we're just a small stumble away from the sun not coming up or water not being wet or fire not being hot or food not digesting that you're sort of in conversation with roiling energy with your entire culture your architecture your your language you know i don't know as much about the language as you do, but is there a reflection there? A reflection of what? Like the concept of the teot that you talk about and the way that language is. Yeah, language actually is a way of transmitting life energy or teot.
我们总是试图……你知道，我们离太阳不升起、水不再湿润、火不再热或食物无法消化只有一步之遥。你整个文化、建筑、语言都在与这种翻腾的能量对话。我不知道你对语言了解多少，但那里有反映吗？反映什么？比如你谈到的“特奥特”概念以及语言的方式。是的，语言实际上是一种传递生命能量或“特奥特”的方式。
And the principal way actually for the Mexica and other Mesoamerican peoples as well, the principal way of what we would call worshipping or honoring or revering the deities, who are actually not sort of deities in the Western sense, is through song and poetry, through the spoken word. So words are powerful, unlike we think sticks and stones will break your bones, but words never hurt you for them was actually are causally potent yeah so the principal way of worshiping the deities is actually through song spoken word what we would call prayer and then that's and this is made very clear in a kichemaya text called the popuh, in which the gods there create human beings who can speak properly because it's only through proper speech that humans can properly nourish and refuel and sustain the so-called gods. So on this view, I mean, those things we call gods are in fact dependent upon human beings. So there's a symbiotic relationship between
对于墨西加人和其他中美洲民族来说，我们所谓的崇拜、尊崇或敬畏神灵（他们实际上并不是西方意义上的神灵）的主要方式，是通过歌唱和诗歌，通过口头语言。所以词语是有力量的，不像我们认为的“棍棒和石头会打断你的骨头，但言语永远不会伤害你”，对他们来说，言语实际上具有因果效力。是的，崇拜神灵的主要方式实际上是通过歌唱、口头语言，也就是我们所说的祈祷。这一点在基切玛雅（Kiche Maya）的文献《波波尔·乌》（Popol Vuh）中说得很清楚，神灵创造了能够正确说话的人类，因为只有通过正确的言语，人类才能适当地滋养、补充和维持所谓的神灵。所以在这个观点下，我们称之为神的东西实际上依赖于人类。因此，存在一种共生关系。
humans and so-called deities it's actually the metaphysics is a form of pantheism where it's just one thing teo it's powerful it's sacred it's all encompassing everything is ultimately one with it and what we call deities are simply what some anthropologists call other-than-human persons, a little less derogatory than non-humans. But so there are all these other-than-human persons in the world, tables, chairs, cats, dogs, trees, lakes, mountains. And some of those are also people like Quetzalcoatl or Tlaloc, who are typically described as deities, but they're just simply more powerful than human persons. So they create us, but they create us in order to nourish them, because they're exhausted after creating the world.
人类和所谓的神灵之间，实际上这种形而上学是一种泛神论，即只有一种东西——“特奥特”。它是强大的、神圣的、包罗万象的，一切最终都与它合一。我们称之为神灵的，仅仅是人类学家所说的“非人类的人”（other-than-human persons），这比“非人类”稍微不那么贬义。所以世界上有所有这些“非人类的人”：桌子、椅子、猫、狗、树、湖泊、山脉。其中一些也是像羽蛇神（Quetzalcoatl）或特拉洛克（Tlaloc）这样的人，他们通常被描述为神灵，但他们只是比人类更强大的人。所以他们创造了我们，但他们创造我们是为了滋养他们，因为他们在创造世界后精疲力竭。
So we're created and we're born inde indebted to them because we owe our life and our existence to them so we then gift back to them various things spoken word poetry song music burning copal incense human hearts and flesh to be sure as well as
所以我们被创造出来，生来就欠他们的债，因为我们的生命和存在归功于他们。所以我们回赠给他们各种东西：口头语言、诗歌、歌唱、音乐、燃烧柯巴脂（copal incense）、人类的心脏和血肉，当然还有
tortillas amaranth bill figures a variety of foodstuffs okay right um and they then then re-nourish us through the revitalization of of nature's maze through agriculture so there's a mutual there's a symbiotic relationship between humans and the so-called deities. We depend upon them and they depend upon us. So there's a very dramatic contrast with the notion of a god. I think even in like Greek, Roman, and Abrahamic religions, the gods are not dependent upon human beings. This whole idea is modeled upon the symbiotic relationship between cultivated maize and human beings.
玉米饼、苋菜面团人偶，以及各种食物。好的，没错。然后他们通过大自然的复苏，通过农业，通过玉米来重新滋养我们。所以人类和所谓的神灵之间存在一种相互的、共生的关系。我们依赖他们，他们也依赖我们。因此，这与“上帝”的概念形成了非常鲜明的对比。我认为即使在希腊、罗马和亚伯拉罕宗教中，神灵也不依赖于人类。整个这个想法是基于耕种的玉米与人类之间的共生关系而建立的。
Maize cannot reproduce without human intervention. If you look at a dried up maize husk, I mean, the corn kernels, the seeds in there are trapped inside that husk and they cannot get out. For maize to reproduce, it requires human intervention. For us to reproduce, we need maze intervention, so to speak. We need to consume maze. So maze and human beings are symbiotic. They're mutually interdependent. And that's the Mashika's model for the relationship between humans and the gods, and actually humans and the whole cosmos. The cosmos cannot reproduce without human beings nourishing it, and we cannot
没有人类的干预，玉米就无法繁殖。如果你看一个干枯的玉米壳，玉米粒被困在那个壳里，它们无法出来。玉米要繁殖，需要人类的干预。我们要繁殖，需要玉米的干预，可以说。我们需要消耗玉米。所以玉米和人类是共生的。它们是相互依存的。这就是墨西加人关于人类与神灵，实际上是人类与整个宇宙之间关系的模式。没有人类的滋养，宇宙就无法繁殖，而我们无法
reproduce without the cosmos nourishing us. So when it comes to any sort of notion of we think of there a sacred profane God versus human distinction, it falls apart because ultimately we eat the gods in the form of peas in water, and they eat us in the form of our blood or our flesh. So we eat godly stuff. They eat humanly stuff and you are what you eat. That makes us very, very actually at the end of the day, um, identical on speaking in terms of what we're made out of. We're interlinked, interlinked that all of the different aspects of creation are always connected to the next one. Not just interlinked, but made up of the same stuff.
在没有宇宙滋养的情况下繁殖。所以，当我们谈到我们认为的神圣与世俗、上帝与人类的区别时，这种观念就瓦解了，因为最终我们以玉米水的形式吃掉神灵，而他们以我们的血液或血肉的形式吃掉我们。所以我们吃神圣的东西，他们吃人类的东西，你吃什么就是什么。这使得我们最终在构成成分上实际上是完全相同的。我们是相互关联的，创造的所有不同方面总是与下一个相连。不仅仅是相互关联，而是由同一种东西构成的。
Right. So there's no nature, super nature distinction. It cuts between that. That's one of these dualisms we get out of Western philosophy. It almost feels like quantum physics, part of it. Well, yes. I mean, I don't know enough to intelligently address that, but a lot of people would say so. Yeah. There's some really good work done by an Andeanist named Marisol de la Cadena. She wrote a book called Earth Beings. She discusses a very similar notion in indigenousean indigenous andean philosophy and she does appeal to contemporary quantum mechanics so you end up if you follow kind of math or neurology
没错。所以没有自然与超自然的区别。它打破了这种界限。这是我们从西方哲学中得到的二元论之一。这几乎感觉像是量子物理学，部分是这样。嗯，是的。我的意思是，我不知道得足够多，无法智能地讨论这个问题，但很多人会这么说。是的。一位名叫玛丽索尔·德拉卡德纳（Marisol de la Cadena）的安第斯研究学者做了一些非常出色的工作。她写了一本书叫《大地存在》（Earth Beings）。她讨论了土著安第斯哲学中一个非常相似的概念，她确实诉诸了当代量子力学。所以如果你追随数学或神经学，
too far to one direction you sort of end up in metaphor and and away from numbers in a way that makes the empiricists sort of frustrated i think yeah yeah true enough well i mean there's like a present tenseness to the kind of religious process you're describing that is not really in other cultures i mean there's if you look at greek or norse or something i mean there's like a history where the gods did a bunch of stuff and then they quit and now they've sort of gone to another place and we still have to sometimes beg them to deign to notice us or show that we remember them to not get punished. But it isn't part of every part of life. You know, it isn't part of food.
走得太远，你最终会陷入隐喻，远离数字，这让经验主义者感到沮丧，我想。是的，确实如此。好吧，我的意思是，你描述的那种宗教过程有一种“现在时态”，这在其他文化中并不真正存在。我的意思是，如果你看希腊或北欧神话，有一段历史，神灵做了一堆事情，然后他们退出了，现在他们去了另一个地方，我们有时还得乞求他们屈尊注意到我们，或者表现出我们记得他们，以免受到惩罚。但这并不是生活的一部分。你知道，它不是食物的一部分。
It isn't part of art. It isn't part of culture in this way that you describe it being in the book. And to me, like Aztec architecture was almost kind of like overwhelming to look at. Like when you look at the pictures, it's like pictures within pictures within pictures like it looks like a magic eye there's a serpent wrapped around the whole building with the serpent so big that the pieces of the serpent are making this tableau but then in that tableau there's other little things and so i always thought you know when i was younger well that's just how they did architecture but you go back to the olmecs and the toltecs the empires before that and the architecture looks greek almost like the figure the wrestler they excavated i mean it's very kind
它不是艺术的一部分。它不是你书中描述的那种文化的一部分。对我来说，阿兹特克建筑看起来几乎令人不知所措。当你看到图片时，就像画中画，看起来像一张魔眼图。有一条蛇缠绕在整个建筑上，蛇大到蛇的碎片构成了这幅画面，但在那幅画面中还有其他小东西。所以我年轻时总认为，那是他们做建筑的方式。但你回到奥尔梅克（Olmec）和托尔特克（Toltec）时期，即之前的帝国，建筑看起来几乎像希腊风格，比如他们挖掘出的摔跤手雕像，非常……
of traditional so do you think that architecture is a reflection of the kind of metaphysics you're describing that all of this stuff is interlinked and put together i mean things like the moon disc that they excavated and tanakti clan i mean that looks like a picasso painting it looks like guernica or something you know like in a way that you know it took us hundreds of years to rediscover that kind of impressionistic felt uh sense of art yeah yeah yeah um i mean i think i my sense is that the sort of metaphysics that i'm attributing to the Aztecs is actually deeply entrenched within and widely spread within Mesoamerica. So it would be there in the Olmecs, the Toltecs, Mixtecs, Zapotecs, and Maya as well. I know there's not a lot of historical record left. Aztecs are trying to link their leaders to the leaders of the past
传统。所以你认为建筑反映了你所描述的那种形而上学，即所有这些东西都是相互关联并组合在一起的？我的意思是，像他们在特诺奇蒂特兰挖掘出的月亮圆盘，看起来像毕加索的画，看起来像《格尔尼卡》或者其他什么。你知道，我们花了数百年才重新发现那种印象派的艺术感。是的，是的。嗯，我的意思是，我的感觉是，我归因于阿兹特克人的那种形而上学实际上在中美洲根深蒂固且广泛传播。所以它也会存在于奥尔梅克人、托尔特克人、米斯特克人（Mixtecs）、萨波特克人（Zapotecs）和玛雅人中。我知道留下的历史记录不多。阿兹特克人试图将他们的领袖与过去的领袖联系起来
empire for legitimacy and things but i mean from your impression you know you can't say anything super uh concrete a lot of the time but from your impression why is the aztec art architecture so different than olmec's toltecs if that uh metaphysical assumption was not changed i guess i mean there isn't that much toltec art around and it doesn't strike me as all that dissimilar actually um actually and a lot of the uh aztec art is modeled directly after the toltec art because they did visit Tula, the archaeological remains of Tolan or where the Toltecs were. And there's lots of art within the so-called sacred precinct, the ceremonial center of Tenochtitlan that's modeled closely after it.
以获得合法性。但从你的印象来看，你知道，很多时候你不能说出非常具体的东西，但从你的印象来看，为什么阿兹特克艺术建筑与奥尔梅克、托尔特克如此不同，如果那种形而上学的假设没有改变的话？我的意思是，周围没有那么多托尔特克艺术，实际上它给我的印象并没有那么不同。嗯，实际上，许多阿兹特克艺术是直接模仿托尔特克艺术的，因为他们确实参观过图拉（Tula），即托兰（Tolan）的考古遗迹，或者托尔特克人所在的地方。在特诺奇蒂特兰所谓的圣区（ceremonial center）内，有很多艺术品是紧密模仿它的。
So I don't think there's a, I mean, there's a big difference. Olmecs. I mean, yeah, I, other than that, I can't really, I don't know why they are different.
所以我认为没有……我的意思是，有一个很大的区别。奥尔梅克人。我的意思是，是的，除此之外，我真的不知道为什么它们不同。
Um, their explanation would be that what we're calling art is in fact, not art. It's in fact alive. Um, the whole notion of attributing to other cultures a western notion of art is basically misguided um those things are all living persons um there's a very famous well not so very film that i when i was at visited the humboldt Forum in Berlin last summer.
嗯，他们的解释会是，我们称之为艺术的东西实际上并不是艺术。它实际上是活的。嗯，将西方艺术概念归因于其他文化的整个观念基本上是误导的。那些东西都是活生生的人。有一个非常著名的……嗯，不是那么著名的电影，我去年夏天在柏林洪堡论坛（Humboldt Forum）参观时看到的。
There's a quote from a film, I believe it translates, it's a French film made in the 50s. The French title translates as something like, Even Statues Die. And there was a quote from it right next to the Benin Bronzes that the Humboldt Forum owns. And it says, when men die, right, it's quote, when men die, they become history. When statues die, they become art.
有一部电影的引语，我相信它是这样翻译的，那是一部50年代制作的法国电影。法文标题翻译过来大概是《即使是雕像也会死亡》。在洪堡论坛拥有的贝宁青铜器旁边，有一句来自该片的引语。它说，当人死亡时，对，它是引语，“当人死亡时，他们成为历史。当雕像死亡时，它们成为艺术。”
So there's this idea that all these things are alive and that they're living, and that when they get conquered and colonized, we come in and go, oh, no, that's art, because we're unwilling to see that what you that dismembered figure at the bottom there is actually probably still alive and was alive in some sense for the aztecs but paintings sculptures these things are all alive and this tends to be pretty much a what we call new world wide phenomenon that native people see even geometric figures as sort of, in some sense, vivifying and alive.
所以有一种观点认为所有这些东西都是活的，它们是有生命的。当他们被征服和殖民时，我们走进去说，哦，不，那是艺术，因为我们不愿意看到你底部那个被肢解的人物实际上可能仍然活着，并且在某种意义上对阿兹特克人来说是活着的。但绘画、雕塑，这些东西都是活的。这往往是一个我们称之为“新世界”的普遍现象，即土著人甚至将几何图形视为某种意义上的赋予生命和活着的。
Some patterns are compatible with you eat out of a bowl with certain patterns. You don't eat out of a bowl with other patterns. The pattern has a causal effect upon things. And so in a sense, it's energized and vivifying as well. And so, yeah, back to why the Aztecs would claim that they're painting their gods the way they do, they're building their buildings the way they do because they've been told to do so. It's not simply a matter of artistic convention or style, individual whimsy.
有些图案是兼容的，你用带有特定图案的碗吃饭。你不会用带有其他图案的碗吃饭。图案对事物有因果影响。因此，在某种意义上，它也是充满能量和赋予生命的。所以，回到为什么阿兹特克人会声称他们以那种方式描绘他们的神灵，他们以那种方式建造他们的建筑，因为他们被告知要这样做。这不仅仅是艺术惯例或风格、个人奇思妙想的问题。
The gods don't let you depict them any, just any way willy nilly. There's a specific way in which they want you to do that. So the sculptor, the artist, the painter has these communications, conversations with the gods, and the gods tell them how they wish to be presented, not re-presented, but presented, because the god there in all its fullness. The analogy that will come most to mind for us is,
神灵不会让你随意描绘他们。他们希望你以特定的方式去做。所以雕塑家、艺术家、画家与神灵有这些交流、对话，神灵告诉他们希望如何被呈现，而不是“再现”，因为神灵就在那里，处于其全部的丰满中。最容易让我们想到的类比是，
think about the Eucharist and communion for Catholics, right? You eat the wafer, that is Jesus's flesh. You drink the wine, that is Jesus's blood. Protestants take over and it becomes symbolic of Jesus's flesh, symbolic of Jesus's blood. But for the Catholics, especially pre-Reformation Catholics, I mean, it's there, and Jesus is in there, and Jesus' flesh and his essence is in there.
想想天主教徒的圣餐礼，对吧？你吃下圣饼，那就是耶稣的肉。你喝下葡萄酒，那就是耶稣的血。新教徒接手后，它变成了耶稣肉的象征，耶稣血的象征。但对于天主教徒，尤其是宗教改革前的天主教徒，我的意思是，它就在那里，耶稣就在里面，耶稣的肉和他的本质就在里面。
Analogously for the Meshika, a statue of, let's say, Tlaloc or Quetzalcoatl, Quetzalcoatl is right there. That is Quetzalcoatl. Quetzalcoatl is right there. That is Quetzalcoatl. It's not a representation, picture of, depiction of, symbol of Quetzalcoatl. It is Quetzalcoatl. And you can talk with him one-on-one. So they are presentations, not re-presentations. This whole notion of everything being a symbol or a picture of, a of a representative of is all comes out of the reformate the Protestant Reformation and semiotics, which comes out of that as well. So. For them, this stuff is not strictly speaking art, just other persons made out of stone or ink and paper or aid. well a lot that jumps out there that's fascinating i
类似地，对于墨西加人来说，比如特拉洛克或羽蛇神的雕像，羽蛇神就在那里。那就是羽蛇神。羽蛇神就在那里。那就是羽蛇神。它不是羽蛇神的再现、图片、描绘或象征。它就是羽蛇神。你可以和他一对一地交谈。所以它们是“呈现”，而不是“再现”。所有这些关于一切都是象征、图片或代表的观念，都源于新教改革和符号学，而符号学也源于此。所以，对他们来说，这些东西严格来说不是艺术，只是由石头、墨水和纸或芦苇制成的其他人。好吧，很多跳出来的内容都很迷人。我
mean firstly that quote that you share seems like you found something that was incredibly in keeping with the philosophy behind your book in that museum that's that's a really beautiful statement and two it sounds like you know the communion is a lot more of a ritual it is a communing with but it doesn't change and it's not up to the participant what it looks like. What you're describing about being told by the gods what kind of art they want to make sounds like a pretty poetic description of intuition, you know. Yeah, well, they wouldn't call it intuition because they would call it oracular communication. Yeah, well, I think some jungians would maybe call intuition that too uh who would uh some jungian analysts yeah well yeah i mean if if your worldview assumes
首先，你分享的那句引语，似乎你在那个博物馆里发现了一些与你书背后的哲学极其契合的东西，那是一个非常美丽的陈述。第二，听起来你知道，圣餐礼更多是一种仪式，它是一种交流，但它不会改变，看起来什么样也不是由参与者决定的。你描述的关于被神灵告知他们想要制作什么样的艺术，听起来像是对直觉的一种相当诗意的描述，你知道。是的，好吧，他们不会称之为直觉，因为他们会称之为神谕交流。是的，好吧，我想一些荣格派学者可能也会称之为直觉，那些……一些荣格派分析师。是的，好吧，我的意思是，如果你的世界观假设
the world view of modern natural science then yeah all of this talk has to be recast in terms of intuitions or stuff in the head or symbols. I don't know about the de-romanticization of nature that happens. Weber talks about it and others. With modern science, qualities, colors, tastes, sounds, the magical, all of that, which is even within European metaphysics, pre-Galileo, pre-natural science, all of that just gets sucked out of nature and put into our heads. It's all up here now. It's not out there because the only thing out there is physics, right? A world matter in motion with quantitative properties alone yeah oh yeah i'm so i'm not gonna go with you yeah with you to union land or freudian land or semiotics land because
现代自然科学的世界观，那么是的，所有这些谈话都必须被重塑为直觉、头脑中的东西或符号。我不知道自然界的“去浪漫化”发生了什么。韦伯（Weber）和其他人谈论过它。随着现代科学的发展，品质、颜色、味道、声音、魔法，所有这些，即使在欧洲形而上学中，在伽利略之前，在自然科学之前，所有这些都被从自然界中吸走，放进了我们的头脑里。它现在都在这里了。它不在外面，因为外面唯一的东西是物理学，对吧？一个只有定量属性的物质运动世界。是的，哦，是的，我不会和你一起去荣格之地或弗洛伊德之地或符号学之地，因为
i'm i'm not so much interested in explaining in some sort of scientific or Western sense why they think what they do. I'm trying to understand, in fact, what they do think. Sure. And then if you want to explain it this other way, that's fine. But I devote myself to trying to get in their heads and understanding what's going on. Yeah, no, and I'm not at all trying to pull you out of that experience i just know a lot of uh especially older unions that are kind of part of the transpersonal um psychology movement view the self not really as an individual but as a part of systems interacting with the world and
我不太感兴趣用某种科学或西方的意义来解释他们为什么那样想。我实际上是在试图理解他们到底在想什么。当然。然后如果你想用另一种方式解释它，那没关系。但我致力于试图进入他们的头脑，理解正在发生的事情。是的，不，我根本不是想把你从那种体验中拉出来。我只是知道很多，特别是老一辈的荣格派学者，他们是超个人心理学运动的一部分，他们并不真正将自我视为一个个体，而是视为与世界互动的系统的一部分，并且
and also interacting with the body it's more um for that kind of academic psychology, I think, unfortunately, views the body as this go-kart that carries the brain around and the brain does all the thinking in it. We might as well just pluck it out and put it in the jar because that's all we are. There are alternative psychologies today that are popping up as we try and do things. Yeah, yeah, fair enough. alternative psychologies today that are popping up as we try and do things. Yeah. Fair enough. Um, but so you, Tia,
也与身体互动。对于那种学术心理学来说，不幸的是，它将身体视为载着大脑到处跑的卡丁车，大脑在里面做所有的思考。我们还不如把它拔出来放进罐子里，因为我们就是这样。今天出现了替代心理学，当我们尝试做事情时。是的，是的，很有道理。今天出现的替代心理学，当我们尝试做事情时。是的。很有道理。嗯，但是你，特奥特，
you say in the book has kind of three main manifestations that sometimes overlapped and interact. Could you, could you go through those manifestations of the energy that, cause I think those are important, um, you know, ways to, to help understand what your,
你在书中说它有三种主要的表现形式，有时会重叠和互动。你能，你能过一遍那些能量的表现形式吗？因为我认为那些很重要，嗯，你知道，帮助理解你的，
what your point is there. Sure. So tailed is this sort of constant energy in motion always changing always becoming always moving always processing so that foundation gives you a pantheism it also gives you what western philosophers call a process metaphysics that the basic stuff of the universe is are processes not things right and this contrasts with the dominant mode in western philosophy starting with plato at least that the building blocks of the world are things of one kind or another that are permanent you
你的观点是什么。当然。所以“特奥特”是这种持续运动的能量，总是变化，总是成为，总是移动，总是处理。所以那个基础给了你一种泛神论，它也给了你西方哲学家所说的“过程形而上学”，即宇宙的基本构成是过程，而不是事物，对吧？这与西方哲学中从柏拉图开始的主流模式形成了对比，即世界的基石是某种永久的事物。你
know they can be atoms for plato they be forms. We could think they're substances, entities, things. But the world, the furniture of the universe consists of things. Process metaphysics argues that the furniture, if that's appropriate of the universe, are processes. Parades, seasons, rainfalls, waterfalls, floodings, things going on. So the world is always moving always changing always transforming into something else so the three patterns that that pale adopts um in this and motion here also includes change right we think of motion as just going from point a to point b but if you go back to aristotle changing through let's get moving through your the life cycle from point A to point B. But if you go back to Aristotle, changing through, let's say,
知道，它们可以是原子，对于柏拉图来说，它们是形式。我们可以认为它们是实体、存在、事物。但世界，宇宙的家具由事物组成。过程形而上学认为，宇宙的家具（如果这样称呼合适的话）是过程。游行、季节、降雨、瀑布、洪水，正在进行的事情。所以世界总是在移动，总是在变化，总是转化为其他东西。所以“特奥特”采用的三种模式，嗯，在这个过程中，这里的运动也包括变化，对吧？我们认为运动只是从A点到B点，但如果你回到亚里士多德，通过……让我们通过……
moving through the life cycle from infancy to young adulthood to old age, that's a kind of movement. So they agree on that. So there's not only physical movement from point A to point B, but there's also motion in the sense of going through a life change, you know, aiding, dying, life renewal. So there's three patterns. One is called Olin. And so it is the kind of motion which is exhibited by a bouncing ball. It's sort of, is this parabolic like that?
通过生命周期从婴儿期到青年期再到老年期，那是一种运动。所以他们同意这一点。所以不仅有从A点到B点的物理运动，还有在经历生命变化意义上的运动，你知道，衰老、死亡、生命更新。所以有三种模式。一种叫“奥林”（Olin）。所以它是弹跳球所表现出的那种运动。它是一种，是这种抛物线吗？
As I recall, yeah. Boun sort of, uh, per is this parabolic like that? As I recall. Yeah. Um, bouncing ball, beating heart. It's also the, the motion through the four stages of our life cycle. So there's a kind of specific motion and they depicted in a particular kind of way.
我记得是。弹跳，某种……是这种抛物线吗？我记得。是的。嗯，弹跳球，跳动的心脏。它也是我们生命周期四个阶段的运动。所以有一种特定的运动，他们以一种特定的方式描绘它。
So it's like an oscillation almost. Yeah. It's bouncing between two. And the sun going up and down and up and down, up and over, up and over, up and over the surface of the earth. That is the pattern or how Teot moves in that particular way. Would any kind of philosophical or natural paradox be seen as that? I know you don't mention
所以它几乎是一种振荡。是的。它在两者之间弹跳。太阳升起又落下，升起又落下，升起又越过，升起又越过，升起又越过地球表面。这就是模式，或者说“特奥特”以那种特定的方式移动。任何哲学或自然悖论会被视为那样吗？我知道你没有提到
that in the book but it was a question paradoxes yeah the idea that you have two things that are paradoxical but both true or something is that ever brought up in a any kind of cultural or i don't think so not least concerning olin okay i was just curious yeah um then there's another kind of motion change, pattern of motion change, right? It's different, not a different kind of energy, but a different pattern of this Taoist constant moving and becoming,
在书中，但这是一个问题。悖论，是的，你有两个悖论但都正确的东西的想法，或者某种东西，这在任何文化中被提出来过吗？或者我不知道。我不这么认为，至少关于“奥林”不是。好的，我只是好奇。是的，嗯，然后还有另一种运动变化，运动变化的模式，对吧？它不同，不是一种不同的能量，而是这种“特奥特”持续移动和成为的另一种模式，
which is spiraling, when they call that Malanali. And that's the pattern of energy it takes for transmitting energy between levels of the cosmos, the levels of the universe. So if I want to get energy going up to, if I want to transmit life energy to the gods
也就是螺旋，他们称之为“马兰纳利”（Malanali）。那是它在宇宙各层级、宇宙各层面之间传递能量所需的能量模式。所以如果我想让能量上升，如果我想把生命能量传递给神灵，
up since they reside above me, I spin it, I order it, I do that. And that is how energy is transmitted from below the earth to the surface of the earth above the earth you said that was how they viewed digestion was a whirling of food right fire is conceived as that and they see fire as a act as a as a burning as i was wondering if some of the sacrifice rituals couldn't almost be like a reverse digestion that you're taking a living thing and spiraling it back up into this cosmic energy to feed the gods um yeah yeah i mean i don't know about reverse digestion but in
因为他们居住在我之上，我旋转它，我整理它，我这样做。这就是能量如何从地表之下传递到地表之上。你说过那是他们看待消化的方式，是食物的旋转，对吧？火被认为是那样的，他们将火视为一种行为，一种燃烧。我当时在想，一些祭祀仪式是否几乎就像一种反向消化，你把一个活的东西，把它螺旋式地送回这种宇宙能量中去喂养神灵。嗯，是的，是的，我的意思是，我不知道关于反向消化，但在
i mean i'm thinking of you take the food and you put it into the person to make the person uh sort of taking the food out of the person to put it back into the yeah well it's i mean reverse just to say that it's cyclical, right? You're always, we're always meant to be recycling the life energies, which the gods have given us, recycling them back to them. So yeah, you're right. One of the more sort of dramatic examples is there's so-called gladiator stone. You can look it up, but it's once again not appropriately called that
我的意思是，我在想你把食物放进人身体里来制造人，嗯，某种程度上把食物从人身体里拿出来放回……是的，好吧，我的意思是，反向消化，它是循环的，对吧？你总是，我们总是被意图循环神灵给我们的生命能量，把它们循环回给他们。所以是的，你是对的。其中一个比较戏剧性的例子是所谓的“角斗士石”。你可以查一下，但它再次不被恰当地称为那个，
but it's a was a circular um like a pedestal on which uh captured warrior would uh engage in combat ritual combat but it was they had actual weapons with mashika warriors um and what they would do is spin them around. They'd rotate around, round and round this circular pedestal. And in the process also try to kill them at first, but just do what they would call stripe them, to nick them so that he would bleed and spread his blood around this thing. And this thing actually, the word for it is the word for a spindle whorl. And the spindle whorl, as you know, is the heavy weight you put in the word for a spindle whorl and the spindle whorl as you know is the heavy weight you put in the bottle of bottom of a spindle rod when you're spinning raw cotton into
但它是一个圆形的……像一个基座，被俘的战士会在上面进行战斗，仪式性战斗。但他们有真正的武器，与墨西加战士一起。他们会做的是让他们旋转。他们会绕着这个圆形基座转圈。在这个过程中，起初也试图杀死他们，但只是做他们所说的“划伤”，去割伤他们，这样他就会流血，并把他的血洒在这个东西周围。而这个东西，实际上，它的词是“纺锤轮”（spindle whorl）的词。而纺锤轮，如你所知，是当你把生棉花纺成……时，你放在纺锤杆底部的重物。
um fun cotton and it's a way of ordering so what they did was they spun them around like this and that would in fact transmit the energy in his blood up to the cosmos so yeah that's one of the ways they recycle it um well i think when someone's saying oh this is so alien and bizarre and brutal or something but when you're understanding these assumptions as that the universe excuse me is always being sustained by itself and going through these things and it's our job to sustain it i mean you're just taking the heart back out of the body giving it back to the gods unfortunately this guy lost the flower war now and then later that will be me and there was a sense of being um comfortable even if the
嗯，有趣的棉花，这是一种整理方式。所以他们所做的是让他们像这样旋转，那实际上会把他的血液中的能量传递到宇宙中。所以是的，那是他们循环它的方式之一。嗯，我想当有人说“哦，这太离奇、怪异和残酷了”时，但当你理解这些假设，即宇宙——对不起——总是被自身维持并经历这些事情，而我们的工作是维持它时，我的意思是，你只是把心脏从身体里拿出来，还给神灵。不幸的是，这家伙现在输掉了花之战，然后以后那会是我。有一种舒适感，即使
individual maybe didn't like it the society was comfortable and natural with it as just this inevitable thing that's kind of going to happen anyway you know i'm thinking of that like what is it in the bhagavad-gita um where the line where the guy's like i don't really want to fight all these people like it just seems like a mean thing to kill all of them and you know she was says even without your sword behold i have become time even without your sword all of these men will crumble and turn into dust what you do is nothing you know yeah i can see that yeah i mean i mean there's but there's not an eventuality in the aztec case at least to the extent i understand the eventuality in the example you just gave this stuff isn't going to happen eventually unless i mean because human beings actually need to intervene yeah beyond the continuing existence of the cosmos
个体可能不喜欢它，社会对它感到舒适和自然，认为这只是不可避免的事情，无论如何都会发生。你知道，我在想那个，比如《薄伽梵歌》里是什么？那句台词，那个人说“我真的不想和所有人战斗，杀掉他们似乎是一件卑鄙的事情”，你知道，奎师那说“即使没有你的剑，看吧，我已经成为了时间。即使没有你的剑，所有这些人也会崩溃并化为尘土。你所做的一切什么都不是。”你知道，是的，我能理解。是的，我的意思是，我的意思是，但在阿兹特克的情况下，至少在我理解的范围内，没有那种必然性。在你刚才给的例子中，除非……因为人类实际上需要干预，是的，超越宇宙的持续存在。
i mean all of nature as we would call it requires human participation and intervention and i'm not whereas human beings created specifically for that job. That's our, that's our purpose. Um, so I'm not trying to compare it to Hinduism in that way, but I do want to try and reach the person who still is not, uh,
我的意思是，我们所称的所有自然界都需要人类的参与和干预，我不是……而人类是专门为那项工作创造的。那是我们的，那是我们的目的。嗯，所以我不是试图以那种方式将其与印度教进行比较，但我确实想尝试接触那些仍然没有，嗯，
feels disconnected from, um, this set of assumptions as, as part of, yeah, something that they can understand. For sure. I mean, and I, you know, I think it would be mistaken to think that everybody was on board, especially, I mean, especially some of the victims or heart donors, unwilling heart
感到与这套假设脱节的人，作为，作为，是的，他们可以理解的东西。当然。我的意思是，而且我，你知道，我认为如果认为每个人都同意这一点是错误的，特别是，我的意思是，特别是那些受害者或心脏捐赠者，不情愿的心脏
donors. The warriors, you're right. I mean, that was part of a, you know, warrior cult, military cult. That was part of the honor. You either die in the battlefield or die on the sacrificial stone. And they had a, you know, if they died that way, they had a very honorable post-mortem existence of accompanying the sun for several years every morning and then eventually becoming monarch butterflies. Um, so, but for the rest of their, there were people who had not chattel slavery, but people who had been bought maybe because they owed a lot of money. And those people could be sold to someone else for a sacrifice. And I'm sure they weren't keen on it um well i know campbell
捐赠者。战士，你是对的。我的意思是，那是，你知道，战士崇拜、军事崇拜的一部分。那是荣誉的一部分。你要么死在战场上，要么死在祭祀石上。他们有，你知道，如果他们那样死了，他们有一种非常光荣的死后存在，陪伴太阳几年，每天早上，然后最终变成帝王蝶。嗯，所以，但对于他们的其余部分，有些人不是动产奴隶，而是因为可能欠了很多钱而被买走的人。而那些人可以被卖给别人作为祭品。而且我敢肯定他们并不热衷于此。嗯，好吧，我知道坎贝尔（Campbell）……
used to say that all mythology has to do with you know uh dealing with guilt or shame i don't know that'd go that far but a lot of it is us kind of trying to have a story about things that we have to do anyway and i mean it was an empire and and when the empires empires work by expanding and then when they hit a uh either geologue or geographic or cultural or economic boundary where they can't expand anymore either the empire falls or the front comes home and that front is coming home you have to have some sort of sustaining game where the empire can imperialize itself and these flower wars were basically a way to continue to have we're going to go out we're going to kill the dark bad scary other we're
过去常说所有的神话都与处理内疚或羞耻感有关，我不知道是否能说得那么绝对，但其中很大一部分是我们试图为那些无论如何都必须做的事情编造一个故事。我的意思是，那是一个帝国，而帝国是通过扩张来运作的。当它们遇到地理、文化或经济边界而无法再扩张时，要么帝国崩溃，要么前线撤回。当这种前线撤回时，你必须拥有一种维持性的游戏，让帝国能够实现自我帝国化。这些“花之战”基本上是一种继续进行的方式，即我们要走出去，我们要去杀掉那个黑暗、邪恶、可怕的“他者”，我们要
going to bring it back in except well they're just kind of symbolic of that actually these are football games you know we're gonna we're gonna because the point of the flower wars was not to go out and kill a bunch of people it was to capture them that's what you got rewarded for and then the other side felt the same way right it wasn't one way street their flower wars with the people from tlachcala right they went out in order to seize aztec warriors for the very same purpose so it was a mutually agreed upon thing it wasn't just the aztecs terrorizing the plush the tlachca takens are you familiar with like uh the way the role that football plays in the american south you know the sec have you at least heard of this religious experience that
把它带回来，只不过它们只是那种行为的象征。实际上，这些就像足球比赛，你知道吗？我们要去……因为“花之战”的目的不是为了出去杀掉一大群人，而是为了俘虏他们，那是你获得奖励的原因。另一方也有同样的感觉，对吧？这不是单行道。他们与特拉斯卡拉人（Tlaxcala）进行的“花之战”，他们走出去是为了俘虏阿兹特克战士，目的完全相同。所以这是一件双方都同意的事情，不仅仅是阿兹特克人在恐吓特拉斯卡拉人。你熟悉美国南部足球所扮演的角色吗？比如SEC联盟，你至少听说过这种宗教体验吗？
we do no i haven't if you ever uh i i'm not a huge football fan other than i like cultural anthropology but i if you ever get a chance to come to alabama and see what a game is like in tuscaloosa i wonder if you don't think about the flower wars and the wrong day i mean it's a bloodletting sport is it it i and i don't mean just in the violence but i mean the cultural role where it's like you when i i told my wife when she moved from indiana like when you go to your school the elementary school kids are going to say who do you go for and that means which football team do you like? And they're going to form an opinion of you based on what you say and have an animosity to that you're going to be like, no, no, no, it's okay
我们……不，我没有。如果你有机会去阿拉巴马州看看塔斯卡卢萨（Tuscaloosa）的比赛是什么样子，我想你一定会想到“花之战”。这不仅仅是指暴力，而是指它的文化角色。我告诉我的妻子，当她从印第安纳州搬来时，当你去学校，小学生会问你：“你支持谁？”这意味着你喜欢哪支足球队？他们会根据你的回答对你形成看法，并对你产生敌意。你会觉得，不，不，不，没关系。
because she doesn't like conflict. And then I took her to Tuscaloosa to see a game when she was looking at the quad and they've rented out for an insane amount of money, just a teeny tiny little square on the grass. And people who don't have a ticket to the game, this isn't the stadium, this is the quad of the college, have brought their entire living room, a generator, their lamp, their couch, their big screen, their barbecue grill, and they're just sitting
因为她不喜欢冲突。后来我带她去塔斯卡卢萨看比赛，当她看到方庭（Quad）时，他们花了一大笔钱租下草地上那一小块地方。那些没有比赛门票的人——这不是在体育场里，而是在大学的方庭里——带来了他们的整个客厅、发电机、台灯、沙发、大屏幕电视、烧烤架，他们就坐在那里。
in a recreation of their living room closer to Mecca. Where you can hear the roar of the stadium with a slight delay on your TV and coming directly from the stadium behind you that you don't have a ticket to get into. Wow. So I don't know.
在离麦加更近的地方重现他们的客厅。你可以听到体育场传来的欢呼声，电视上有轻微的延迟，而欢呼声直接从你身后没有门票进入的体育场传来。哇。所以我不知道。
It makes a lot of your book reminded me of that. A lot of, a lot of us culture. I should get the third pattern since you're at the third one. It's down that rabbit hole. Yeah. And it's back and forth motion. It's the motion between, I mean, actually in battle, right?
你的书里有很多内容让我想起了这一点。很多，很多关于我们文化的。既然你讲到了第三种模式，我应该把它记下来。这就像掉进了兔子洞。是的。这是一种来回的运动。这是一种运动，我的意思是，实际上是在战斗中，对吧？
A thrust Perry, thrust Perry, thrust Perry. It's the motion involved in weaving. It's the motion back forth,, forth involved in sexual intercourse. It's a motion that the Meshika see as creating this in-between space, not in a liminal negative way, but it's in a positive way that in this in-between space, something new is created. A third thing, a tertium quid is created between sexual intercourse. That third thing is created as a child and also a union between these two people, which otherwise doesn't exist. And when it comes to weaving, weaving together,
刺击、格挡，刺击、格挡，刺击、格挡。这是编织中涉及的动作。这是性交中涉及的来回动作。这是一种墨西加人（Meshika）视为创造这种中间空间的运动，不是以一种消极的边缘方式，而是以一种积极的方式，即在这种中间空间里，创造出了某种新的东西。第三种事物，一种“第三者”（tertium quid）在性交中被创造出来。那个第三者被创造为一个孩子，也是这两个人之间的一种结合，否则这种结合是不存在的。当谈到编织时，将经线和纬线编织在一起，
warp and weft creates this new thing, a woven shirt, right? And that is one of the most powerful ones because that's involved in balancing. So it's that back forth, back forth, which actually is then also typified in the constant gifting, re-gifting, re-gifting, gifting, re-gifting between humans and gods. They gift us life. We give them life. When you accept a gift, you're obliged to re-gift. So there's this constant sort of back-forth, back-forth mutuality of gifting. I gift you, you gift me. I gift you, you gift me. I invite you to dinner. If you're good manners, you invite me back over to dinner. We go back and forth and back and forth and back and forth. And that creates this unity of interrelatedness between humans and gods. But it also is the model for all human interactions, this mutual gifting.
创造出这种新事物，一件编织的衬衫，对吧？这是最强大的例子之一，因为它涉及平衡。所以这就是那种来回、来回的动作，这实际上也体现在人类与神灵之间不断的赠礼、回礼、再赠礼、再回礼中。他们赐予我们生命。我们给予他们生命。当你接受礼物时，你有义务回礼。所以存在着这种持续的、来回的、相互的赠礼。我送你礼物，你送我礼物。我送你礼物，你送我礼物。我邀请你吃晚饭。如果你有礼貌，你也会邀请我回去吃晚饭。我们来来回回，来来回回。这创造了人类与神灵之间的一种相互关联的统一体。但这同时也是所有人际互动的模式，这种相互赠礼。
Teachers gift life energy to their students. They're therefore indebted, and they are obliged to re-gift something back to their teachers. Parents gift their children lives. Children are obliged to re-gift by taking care of them in their old age. So this notion of this mutual exchange, re-gifting and re-gifting of life energy is very, very central to human, inter-human relationships and human divine relationships as well. And that's the third kind of motion and so this one actually is very defining of the the cosmos itself because the aztecs see the cosmos basically as a woven fabric and it's woven through all these various kinds of actions of human beings and interactions um so despite the aztecs reputation as being bloodthirsty warrior cult i
老师将生命能量赠予学生。因此他们负有债务，他们有义务回赠一些东西给老师。父母将生命赠予孩子。孩子有义务通过在父母年老时照顾他们来回赠。所以这种相互交换、生命能量的赠予与回赠的概念，对于人际关系以及人与神的关系都非常、非常核心。这就是第三种运动，所以这种运动实际上非常定义了宇宙本身，因为阿兹特克人基本上将宇宙视为一种编织的织物，它是通过人类的各种行为和互动编织而成的。嗯，所以尽管阿兹特克人被认为是一个嗜血的战士崇拜群体，我
mean one of the the basic metaphors and but i don't think it is a metaphor that's our talk is that the cosmos is this weaving in progress this back forth back forth between between polarities male female male female life male, female, life, death, life, death, hot, cold, day, night, day, night, winter, summer, winter, summer. You want to keep that back and forth going in this balanced way, and that maintains the cosmos in a balanced state. It almost sounds like a description of philosophy itself, too. One person has this discourse with this other person,
意思是，其中一个基本隐喻——但我认为这不仅仅是一个隐喻，那是我们的谈话——宇宙就是这种正在进行的编织，这种在两极之间的来回运动：男性、女性，男性、女性，生命、死亡，生命、死亡，炎热、寒冷，白天、黑夜，白天、黑夜，冬天、夏天，冬天、夏天。你想以这种平衡的方式保持这种来回运动，这能使宇宙保持在一种平衡的状态。这听起来几乎也是对哲学本身的描述。一个人与另一个人进行这种对话，
another thing is created the thesis yeah synthesis yeah yeah i mean it's also very similar to taoism you probably heard you already um these dualities these polarities are like yin yang they're mutually arising mutually interdependent um death arises from life life arises from death you can't be alive without killing something and you can't be dead unless you are alive so there's there's this notion that these dualities or polarities go back and forth and back and forth and that they form a unified duality or a dual unity they don't disappear but they form this tertium quid, this third thing. And so that's very, very fundamental to it, maintaining this circulation, this cyclical day-night, day-night, day-night, winter-summer, winter-summer, male-female, male-female, life-death, life-death, just going on and on. And that's what the cosmos is, this cyclical alternation between these mutually rising, mutually interdependent polarities or dualities.
创造了另一种东西，正题、反题、合题，是的。我的意思是，这也与道教非常相似，你可能已经听说过了。这些二元性、这些两极就像阴阳，它们相互产生、相互依存。死亡源于生命，生命源于死亡。没有杀戮，你就无法活着；除非你活着，否则你无法死亡。所以存在着这样一种观念，即这些二元性或两极来来回回，它们形成了一种统一的二元性或双重统一。它们并没有消失，而是形成了这种“第三者”，这种第三种事物。所以这对于维持这种循环非常、非常基础，这种循环的昼夜、昼夜、昼夜，冬夏、冬夏、冬夏，男女、男女，生死、生死，就这样不断地进行下去。这就是宇宙，是这些相互产生、相互依存的两极或二元性之间的循环交替。
And the idea that you could have something like life without death, eternal life, Christian style is just quite literally nonsensical. It's conceptually absurd. It's like being a brother, an only child and a brother, right? You can't be a brother unless you have a brother, right? And having, or having God be just a man is just as incoherent as a single child brother. Because reproduction requires male-female interaction, right? So how could you possibly just have a male create the universe by himself? It literally makes no sense.
而那种认为你可以拥有像没有死亡的生命、基督教式的永生这样的想法，简直是毫无意义的。这在概念上是荒谬的。这就像是一个兄弟，一个独生子和一个兄弟，对吧？除非你有兄弟，否则你不可能成为兄弟，对吧？而且让上帝仅仅是一个男人，就像一个独生子兄弟一样不连贯。因为繁殖需要男女互动，对吧？所以你怎么可能仅仅让一个男性独自创造宇宙呢？这简直毫无道理。
Yeah. They don't see the disconnection of opposites or time in the way that a lot of other... No. Do you think some of that was influenced by there being less written language, accessible, that most interaction is verbal that the civilization is smaller do you see any kind of cultural reality reinforcing that belief or just kind
是的。他们不像许多其他人那样看待对立面或时间的断裂……不。你认为其中一些是否受到书面语言较少、可获取性较低的影响，即大多数互动是口头的，文明规模较小？你是否看到任何文化现实在强化这种信仰，还是仅仅是
of a product of the culture that didn't come from anything between looking for the outside explanation i mean i think it all it goes back to maize agriculture humans can reproduce without maize maize can reproduce without humans right that is like the keystone to understanding how they can see the universe and that's shared throughout mesoamerica that the the fundamentalness of the human maize relationship um the mayas of many argue do to have a re a written language and embrace the same idea so i don't think it's the dominance of orality which explains it yeah and maze is so important to just why the civilization was able to be there if you go further north in america you're not you're spending all your time kind of hunting and gathering not going to, but you don't have the luxury of building a pyramid just with time,
一种文化的产物，而不是来自任何外部解释？我的意思是，我认为这一切都回到了玉米农业。人类没有玉米也能繁殖，玉米没有人类也能繁殖，对吧？这就像是理解他们如何看待宇宙的基石，这一点在整个中美洲都是共有的，即人与玉米关系的根本性。嗯，许多人认为玛雅人确实有书面语言，但也信奉同样的观点。所以我认为这并不是口头传统的主导地位所能解释的。是的，玉米对于文明之所以能够存在非常重要。如果你去北美更北的地方，你把所有时间都花在狩猎和采集上，你没有奢侈的时间去建造金字塔，
but you also may have to move from the place where you built it. So that. Yeah. But you get May's agriculture in North America. They did. Cahokia.
但你也可能不得不从你建造它的地方搬走。所以。是的。但在北美也有玉米农业。他们确实有。卡霍基亚（Cahokia）。
You got lots of large ceremonial centers, Chaco Canyon going on Canyon to shave Cahokia. I live close to Moundville. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I mean, so they may have, I mean,
你有许多大型仪式中心，查科峡谷（Chaco Canyon），一直到卡霍基亚。我住在芒德维尔（Moundville）附近。是的。是的。是的。哦，我的意思是，所以他们可能，我的意思是，
it strikes me that Cahokia had to be largely maize dependent. Anytime you have a settled existence, you're a farmer. You're farming. And maize is there. And maize traveled down to Maize traveled down to South America and up to North America. It is, I guess,
这让我觉得卡霍基亚在很大程度上必须依赖玉米。任何时候你有了定居的生活，你就是一个农民。你在耕种。而玉米就在那里。玉米传到了南美洲，也传到了北美洲。我想，
just talk with a guy who told me that he thinks that maize went down to the Andes and then a different species went back up north. So it's a really complicated history. But yeah, I think people, humans in the Americas is what ended up transforming something called cc play which is basically a wild grass seed into what we think of as
刚才和一个人谈话，他告诉我他认为玉米传到了安第斯山脉，然后一个不同的物种又传回了北方。所以这是一个非常复杂的历史。但是的，我认为美洲的人类最终将一种叫做“大刍草”（teosinte）的东西——基本上是一种野生草籽——转化成了我们认为的
maize about 6 000 years ago the corn started off about that big it was a little kind of fat wheat berries yeah yeah at best well and it's across all of north and south america but the ability to farm it and the quantity to have the surplus really was kind of a luxury of that region and and some of that was agricultural the farmland and the weather patterns and all that but other parts of it and maybe access to certain varieties of it where they didn't know, have that ability. But there's also the Aztecs ability to like soaking maize in lye to create harmony and preserving and just things that were a technological product that had not really traveled that far. I mean,
玉米，大约在6000年前。玉米刚开始的时候大约那么大，就像一点点肥胖的小麦粒。是的，是的，充其量。好吧，它遍布整个北美和南美，但耕种它的能力以及拥有剩余粮食的数量，确实是该地区的一种奢侈。其中一部分是农业，农田和天气模式等等，但其他部分可能是因为接触到了某些品种，而他们不知道，没有那种能力。但阿兹特克人也有能力，比如将玉米浸泡在碱液中以产生“玉米粉”（hominy），以及保存，这些都是技术产物，并没有真正传播得那么远。我的意思是，
I think it was throughout the Americas. Everybody. Harmony was everywhere. It was associated with Southern. If I'm not mistaken is hominy huh i don't know that one specifically i have to look that up yeah no i mean it's europeans when they brought it back to europe didn't know they needed to soak it in lime and ended up i forget the name of the disease that you get from niacin deficiency i'm not soaking scurvy is it scurvy i know that's vitamin c deficiency i don't know
我认为它遍布整个美洲。每个人。玉米粉到处都有。它与南方有关。如果我没记错的话，是玉米粉，嗯，我不确定那个具体的，我得查一下。是的，不，我的意思是，欧洲人把玉米带回欧洲时，不知道需要把它浸泡在石灰里，结果我忘了那种因烟酸缺乏而导致的疾病的名字了。不是坏血病吗？我知道那是维生素C缺乏症，我不知道
and um and it took them a while to figure it out so no i don't know how they discover that but the making of what's called nishtamol is is yeah it's i think it's all over. Okay. I always associated that Aztec, the Mesoamerican region, with just increased output agriculture. Well, they do have increased output. I mean, that's true. And especially the Aztecs had. But, I mean, as you said, anytime you have settled existence and then have the, what, can afford the surplus labor to be building monumental architecture you've got production which exceeds a certain level so you're absolutely right um but i mean that's also true of the andes yeah yeah and yeah mound culture cahokia i don't know if it's
而且，他们花了一段时间才弄明白。所以不，我不知道他们是怎么发现的，但制作所谓的“尼什塔马尔”（nishtamol）是……是的，我想它到处都是。好的。我总是把阿兹特克、中美洲地区与农业产量的增加联系在一起。好吧，他们确实有增加的产量。我的意思是，那是真的。尤其是阿兹特克人。但是，我的意思是，正如你所说，任何时候你有了定居的生活，然后有能力负担剩余劳动力来建造纪念性建筑，你的产量就超过了某个水平，所以你是绝对正确的。嗯，但这在安第斯山脉也是事实。是的，是的，还有土墩文化，卡霍基亚。我不知道这是否
apocryphal because i you know i'm not an academic and so I don't have to cite sources and things. No one's going to give me an F, but if I get it wrong. But I had like a history teacher a long time ago tell me about some story where the Spanish were like, show us the gods. Whereas whether the gods were the gods and they like take them to some statue or carving and the Spanish smashed it. And the Aztecs are just kind of blasé and they're like look at the gods and they're like no the gods are not here and then they they think they're lied to or something and they're like where are they what are the gods and the aztecs just think they're stupid they're like this is what they look like here you go here's the picture
是伪造的，因为你知道，我不是学者，所以我不需要引用来源之类的东西。没人会给我不及格，但如果我弄错了的话。但我很久以前有一位历史老师给我讲过一个故事，说西班牙人当时说：“把神展示给我们看。”无论神是什么，他们把他们带到某个雕像或雕刻前，西班牙人把它砸碎了。而阿兹特克人只是有点冷漠，他们说：“看神。”他们说：“不，神不在这里。”然后他们认为自己被骗了或者什么的，他们说：“他们在哪里？神是什么？”而阿兹特克人只是觉得他们很蠢，他们说：“这就是他们的样子，给你，这是图片。”
of the process and the spanish keep trying to deface these things and then they're not they don't understand because they're trying to, they think it's like stepping on the cross or breaking an idol. And the Aztecs are just kind of like, this is a blueprint of the universe, man. Like, and you're,
过程的图片，而西班牙人不断试图毁坏这些东西，然后他们不明白，因为他们试图……他们认为这就像踩十字架或打破偶像。而阿兹特克人只是觉得：“伙计，这是宇宙的蓝图。”而且你正在
you're tearing up a piece of paper. I don't, I don't understand what you want me to do. Yeah. I mean, yeah, I don't know that story. It may not be true. It may be a,
撕毁一张纸。我不知道，我不明白你想要我做什么。是的。我的意思是，是的，我不知道那个故事。它可能不是真的。它可能是一个
an allegorical they wouldn't be very happy about you coming in and smashing the statue if the statue in fact were a presentation rather than just a picture but that destroying the statue would by no means destroying the god right i mean take tlaloc right who's associated with rain you know water um ice hailstorms thunder lightning i mean all of tlaloc is in all of those in all of those exemplifications all everywhere all at once in different times and places so all of Tlaloc's in a rainstorm in Alabama while also all of Tlaloc is in a rainstorm in North Dakota so if you could rewind time and go live in the Aztec empire you think you'd do that uh yeah uh i mean just as for an exploratory thing for a couple weeks yeah i'd like to do that especially if i were uh an elite priest maybe or an elite person i you know i think the life
寓言。如果你进去砸碎雕像，他们不会很高兴，如果雕像实际上是一种呈现而不仅仅是一张图片的话。但摧毁雕像绝不意味着摧毁神，对吧？我的意思是，以特拉洛克（Tlaloc）为例，他与雨、水、冰、冰雹、雷电有关。我的意思是，特拉洛克的所有方面都在所有这些例子中，在所有不同的时间和地点同时存在。所以特拉洛克的所有方面都在阿拉巴马州的一场暴雨中，同时也都在北达科他州的一场暴雨中。所以如果你能倒转时间去阿兹特克帝国生活，你觉得你会那样做吗？嗯，是的，嗯，我的意思是，作为一个探索性的事情，待上几个星期，是的，我想那样做。特别是如果我是一个精英祭司，或者一个精英人士。我，你知道，我认为
of commoners was hard they worked hard maize agriculture is a demanding life um personally i wouldn't have wanted to be a warrior um it's just not my thing um so yeah i could see doing it um yeah i mean but i mean i can say that about just about everywhere i think would you i don't know i don't i don't know there's something about the veil to me that seems scary there like i kind of like the veil of yeah time of uncertainty that i can talk about this and intuitively interact with it but if you really go back if you really know and you see something i don't know i feel like there's something about that scares me huh yeah i think it'd be neat i'm intriguing i mean i guess we're assuming that I retain all my current sensibilities and stuff
平民的生活很艰难，他们工作很辛苦，玉米农业是一种要求很高的生活。就我个人而言，我不想成为一名战士，那不是我的菜。所以是的，我可以看到自己那样做。是的，我的意思是，但我可以对几乎任何地方都这么说。我想你会吗？我不知道，我不知道。对我来说，那层面纱有些东西看起来很可怕。我有点喜欢那种不确定性的面纱，我可以谈论它并直观地与它互动。但如果你真的回到过去，如果你真的知道并看到了什么，我不知道，我觉得那里面有些东西让我害怕。嗯，是的，我觉得那会很整洁，很有趣。我的意思是，我想我们假设我保留了我目前所有的感官之类的东西，
so that when I saw part sacrifice, I would be appalled and, um, and yeah, that would be hard to watch for sure. Don't want to meet your heroes or in this case, your academic area. Yeah.
所以当我看到活人祭祀时，我会感到震惊，而且，嗯，那肯定很难看。不想见到你的英雄，或者在这种情况下，你的学术领域。是的。
I don't know. um i i think like conspiracy theory is fascinating though i don't really go in for it and a lot of pseudo archaeology is always like caught up in conspiracy theory a ton of the time that yeah you know some combination of aliens and 5g and pyramids and and stuff but i i'm curious like i know that there's the toltec story that they have basically the toltec empire falls apart when one of the emperors is drinking too much and they put him on a boat and send him to north america i mean do you think that him and that retinue got up there do you think that there's anything that you know i've heard people before because a lot of it on its face it just fails conceptually but the people that say like well the reason why in the four corners you end up with things that you don't associate with um a lot of north american um uh culture just all end up
我不知道。嗯，我，我觉得阴谋论很迷人，虽然我并不真正相信它。很多伪考古学总是陷入阴谋论，大部分时间都是这样。是的，你知道，外星人和5G以及金字塔之类的组合。但我很好奇，我知道有托尔特克（Toltec）的故事，说托尔特克帝国基本上是在一位皇帝喝得太多时崩溃的，他们把他放在船上送到了北美。我的意思是，你认为他和那群随从到了那里吗？你认为有什么……你知道，我以前听人说过，因为很多事情从表面上看在概念上就失败了，但那些人说：“好吧，这就是为什么在四角地区（Four Corners）你会发现一些你不会与很多北美文化联系在一起的东西，比如食人、建筑和各种各样的东西，是因为这位托尔特克皇帝去了那里并引入了这些信息。”我并不真正相信这是合理的，但它是唯一一个从表面上看，我不能说“这在根本上是错误的”的解释。是的，我从来没听说过。我的意思是，我知道一个叫“羽蛇神”（Quetzalcoatliltzin）的人的故事，他是托兰（Tolan）的统治者，托尔特克皇帝，据说他喝了太多的普尔克酒（pulque），而且，我想，试图引诱他的妹妹。但他后来羞愧地自愿离开了，去了东方。然后这被变成了科尔特斯（Cortez）是……该地区其他各个城邦精英的子孙，他们为了让阿兹特克人看起来很糟糕、可怕、愚蠢……而这只是西班牙人推翻帝国的主张。如果他是一位皇帝回来……这是一种有益的
there like cannibalism and architecture and and different things is because this toltec emperor went up there and introduced this information i don't really believe that that's plausible but it's one of the only ones that on on the face of it i can't say well that's wrong for this fundamental yeah i've yeah i've never heard never heard i mean i know of the story of a guy named quetzalcoatliltzin, who was the ruler of Tolan, the Toltec emperor, and that he allegedly had too much pulque to drink and, I guess, attempted to seduce his sister. But then he left voluntarily in shame to the east. And then that gets turned into this idea that Cortez is, the children, the grandchildren of the elite of various other city-states in the area who are out to make the aztecs look bad horrific stupid um and that's it's a spanish claim to throw over the empire if he's an emperor coming back to what it's a beneficial
对科尔特斯来说的故事，他正在回归，这是真的。但我的意思是，如果它看起来是事后的，征服后的，这是一种事后的辩解，而不是之前就存在的。大多数，你知道，蒙特祖马二世（Moctezuma II）据称看到的那些预兆，你知道，鸟类之类的，巴拉巴拉。但学者们已经检查过那些了，它们直接来自中世纪欧洲。所以有人写下了这些东西并说：“哦，是的，阿兹特克人也那样想。”所以你必须非常、非常小心这些来源，因为就像我说的，很多来源都是书写的，这很重要，因为即使在入侵之后，也不是每个人都能写字，只有精英，儿子们，也许还有女儿们，但可能在入侵之后，只有精英的儿子们，也许还有女儿们，但可能只有精英的儿子们被方济各会（Franciscans）带进来，教他们读写，教他们西班牙语和拉丁语，他们倾向于写一些自私自利的故事，因为现在，我的意思是，在很多方面，新西班牙的社会、政治、经济结构与特诺奇蒂特兰（Tenochtitlan）时期、阿兹特克帝国时期保持一致。我们只是换了一个新老板。西班牙皇帝现在是老大，而不是“特拉托阿尼”（platuani），即阿兹特克帝国的统治者。但是，所有的贵族都在试图拍马屁，维持现状。他们过着相当奢华的生活，靠玉米农民的劳动为生，他们想保留所有这些，所以他们试图拍国王和西班牙人的马屁。你
story to cortez that that he's returning it's true but i mean i if it looks post-facto, post-conquest sort of is a post-facto sort of justification rather than one that was there before. Most of the, you know, there are all these omens that Moctezuma II supposedly saw, you know, birds with this, blah, blah, blah. But scholars have examined those and those are straight out of medieval Europe. And then so somebody wrote up these things and said, oh yeah, and the Aztecs thought that too. So you have to be very, very careful with the sources because like I say, a lot of the sources are written and that's important because not everybody could write even after the invasion, only the elite, the sons, and maybe the daughters, but probably after the invasion only the elite the sons and maybe the daughters but probably just the sons of the elite of various city-states were brought in by the
知道，这里正在发生争夺地位和权力的竞争，他们不想沦为平民。他们写的东西让他们的祖先看起来很聪明，而不是野蛮。是阿兹特克人做了所有那些可怕的事情。嗯，或者只是非常……是的，来源非常不可靠，所以你必须……这很有道理。我从来没有想过入侵后的政治，试图以中美洲人的身份用你自己的历史来玩西班牙政治。那是……是的，是的。你认为历史的转折点，科尔特斯基本上打破了规则并在没有许可的情况下入侵，我的意思是，他甚至能够用这么少的人做到这一点真是太神奇了，而且由于很多原因，这几乎没有发生。我的意思是，他们追捕
franciscans and taught how to read and write taught spanish and latin and they tended to write stories which were self-serving because now i mean in a lot of ways, the social, political, economic structure of New Spain remained the same when it was Tenochtitlan, when it was the Aztec Empire. We just had a new boss in town. The Spanish emperor was now the top dog rather than the platuani, the ruler of the Aztec Empire. But so all the nobility are trying to suck up, maintain. They live a rather lavish lifestyle they live off the the labor of the commoners who are the maize farmers and they want to retain all of that so they're trying to suck up to the king and the spaniards didn't you
他，因为他试图……西班牙人追捕他，因为他试图打破规则。你知道，但如果他不这样做，你认为会发生什么？我的意思是，很可能在某个时候有人会进去，那个帝国确实会崩溃。我的意思是，你认为他们还能撑多久？如果科尔特斯从记录中被删除，而你有船只在加勒比海四处航行发现东西，你认为这会改变什么？是的，看起来如果不是他，也会是别人。嗯，你知道，阿兹特克人的朝贡者，对吧？墨西哥周围所有这些较小的城邦，你知道，并不高兴。没有被殖民的人民会乐意向帝国强权纳贡。
know there's this jockeying for position and power taking place and they don't want to be reduced to commoners they're writing things that make their ancestors look smart and not barbarous it was the aztecs who did all that horrible stuff um or just very yeah it's the sources are very dicey so you have to be that's that makes sense i never thought about the post and the post invasion politics of trying to play spanish politics with your own history as a as a mesoamerican that's yeah yeah do you the the hinge point in history where cortez basically breaks the rules and invades without permission i mean it's kind of amazing what that he even was able to do that with so few people and that almost didn't happen for a lot of reasons i mean they came after
有“花之战”，但并不是每个人都参与其中。但他们并不高兴。所以迟早，有人会采取同样的“分而治之”的策略。我的意思是，你必须记住，他们都认为自己是……学者们称之为墨西哥的“微爱国主义”，人们认同城市而不是国家。如果你去过奥地利，奥地利有点像那样。如果你去过奥地利，他们希望你支持他们的球队、他们的啤酒和他们的地区。但是他们并不真正喜欢那个更大的奥地利，他们只是……是的，我的意思是，所以他们并不都认为自己是“我们是土著人民，我们必须团结起来驱逐外国人”。他们认为自己是“我来自特拉斯卡拉，我来自乔卢拉（Cholula），我来自这里，那里”。对吧？而且只是
him for trying to the spanish came after the spanish came after him for trying to break the rules you know but if he doesn't do that what do you think happens i mean it's likely that at some point somebody goes in they do that empire does fall i mean how long do you think they get and what do you think that changes if cortez is just deleted from the record and you have ships knocking around across the caribbean discovering stuff yeah it appears as if if it weren't him it would have been somebody else um the you know the people the tributaries of the aztecs, right? All these smaller city-states around, you know, the greater Mexico were not happy. No colonized people are happy having to pay tribute to an imperial power.
“让我们摆脱阿兹特克人”。这个人承诺会这样做，但不幸的是，你知道，他们认为会产生的理想状态并没有发生，因为他们只是被吸纳进了西班牙帝国，而且可能像以前一样受到糟糕的对待。可能甚至更糟。当然。征服后的死亡人数。那是可怕的。是的。
There were the flower wars, but not everybody engaged in those. But they weren't happy. So sooner or later, someone would have done the same divide and conquer sort of strategy. I mean, and you got to remember that they all saw themselves, what scholars call it, micropatriotism in Mexico, that people identify with a city as opposed to the nation and cream is kind of like that if you ever go to austria austria is kind of like that if you ever go to austria they want you to be into their team and their beer and their region there's but they don't really like the the bigger austria they just yeah i mean like so uh so they didn't all see themselves as like we're indigenous people we have to unite to expel the foreigner they saw themselves as i'm from tlascala i'm from cholula i'm from here there right and there was just like
而且还有，对吧，社区的解体，强迫他们进入“监护征赋制”（encomiendas）或强制种植园系统，所谓的“减缩制”（reducciones）。是的，所以他们都……我不知道那个运动的名字。我之所以知道它，是因为有一个……在塞瓦尼（Suwannee）为我的毕业派对提供餐饮的人有这个艺术品收藏，
let's get rid of the aztecs this guy promises to do it but then unfortunately you know the ideal state which i think they thought was going to result, didn't happen because they just got sucked within the Spanish Empire and probably poorly treated as they were before. Probably even worse. Sure. The death toll after the conquest. It was horrific. Yeah.
但他告诉我，这就像西班牙人教……你知道，征服后的第一代人以欧洲风格绘画，他们可以理解比例、透视和数学，但他们无法让他们掌握欧洲的色彩。所以这些画作就像……基本上是贵族妇女和婴儿之类的，但颜色……很难描述，因为你不能说“哦，他们打破了一条规则”，但它就像关于你如何着色的整个概念，看起来不像那个时期你的大脑想要说“哦，这就是那个东西”。它有一种大地色调的混合，非常非典型。我忘了它的名字了。那是
And there's also, right, breaking up of communities, forcing them into encomiendas or forced plantation systems, what's called reducciones. Yeah, so they all... I don't know the name of the movement. The only reason I know about it is because there was a... The guy who catered my grad party at Suwannee had this collection of artwork,
我唯一一次遇到它，是他向我展示他的一些收藏。但天哪，是的，我不知道，我只是……是的，我不能说任何类似的话。我们文化中有所有这些部分，我们甚至无法看到，你知道，以那种方式看到它们。但是的，有没有什么地方我们没提到？有没有什么你觉得是重要的东西，你想跳回去讲，或者我……我不……嗯，是的，我不……是的，不，我想我们已经涵盖了这些事情。我的意思是，我想……我想，那种对活人祭祀的强迫性关注并不是很有帮助。我的意思是，它在那里。我认为我们赋予它的中心地位比他们赋予的要多。这些仪式持续了整整一个月。他们是非常虔诚的人。当方济各会到达时，他们说：“哇，这些人比欧洲人更虔诚。”
but he was telling me that it was like the Spanish had taught um you know first generation um people after the conquest to paint european style and they could understand the proportion and the perspective and the math of it but they couldn't ever get them to get european color so it would be these pictures of like um basically noble women and babies and things but the colors it's hard to describe because you can't say oh they're breaking one rule but it was like the whole notion of how you colored it didn't look like that period that your brain wanted to say oh that's what this is it had a kind of blending of earth tones that just was kind of atypical i forget the name of it that's
他们只是碰巧被魔鬼欺骗了。我们得把魔鬼换成耶稣。但我的意思是，所以有很多事情在发生，而心脏祭祀无疑是其中的一部分。所以，嗯，祭祀本身的概念并不完全适用，因为它字面意思是“使神圣”（sacra facere）。对他们来说，一切都已经神圣了。所以整个概念并不适用。我的意思是，你可以在很多情况下看到这一点，不情愿的心脏捐赠者将他们的生命能量赠予宇宙。但这不仅仅是这种奴隶般的事情，比如“哦，我们必须安抚神灵，否则他们会杀了我们并惩罚我们”。那全是亚伯拉罕式的。嗯，是的，西方人认为如果他们不杀人，太阳就不会升起的看法。我认为对太阳不会升起的恐惧。
the only place i've ever encountered it was he was showing me his some of his collection but boy yeah i don't know i just yeah i can't say anything like that there's all these parts of our culture we just can't even see you know see them like in that way but yeah is there anywhere we don't get is there anything you feel like is an important uh thing something you want to jump back to or a piece that i i don't um uh yeah i don't yeah no i think we've covered things i mean i think i mean i guess the the sort of obsessive focusing upon human sacrifice is not very helpful. I mean, it's there. I think we attribute more centrality to it than they did. These ceremonies lasted an entire month. They're extremely religious people. When the Franciscans arrived, they were like, wow, these people are more religious than Europeans are.
你的书在说这是宇宙过程的重演的重演的重演方面做得很好。是的。是的。我的意思是，太阳确实不会升起，但这并不是因为太阳生气了。这就像是“去你的，伙计们，我今天不会升起了”。这就像太阳只是饿死了。除非我们喂养它，否则太阳没有能量在每天早晨重生。所以，我的意思是，这确实是一个非常基础的、人类与自然互动的人类农业或园艺模型，我们必须回赠它，以便它能赠予我们。而且，你知道，墨西哥的当代纳瓦特尔语（Nahuatl）使用者会争辩说，西方文化在这方面做得并不好。气候变化——作为土地农民，他们非常清楚这一点——是严重的失衡、未能互惠的结果，那种给予和索取，回赠，我给你，你给我。
They just happen to have been tricked by the devil. we got to switch out the devil with jesus but i mean so there are lots of things going on and the heart sacrifice was one part of it undeniably so um the notion The notion of sacrifice itself doesn't quite apply because it literally means to make sacred, sacra facere. And for them, everything already is sacred. So that whole notion of doesn't apply. I mean, you can just see that in lots of cases, unwilling heart donors gifting their life energies to the cosmos um but it's not just this slavish thing like oh we got to appease the gods are they gonna kill us and punish us that's all abrahamic um there's yeah the the perception that westerners have that if they didn't kill the person the sun wouldn't come up. I think the fear of the sun not coming up.
所以这就是所有那些血腥、可怕的东西的来源，就是我们必须回赠以保持事物的运行。而且可能还有一个政治因素，我们倾向于贬低古代帝国的血腥，或者盯着他们血腥的一面，从而忽视现代帝国是极其血腥的。是的。我们不需要陈述显而易见的事实。房间里的大象。不，天哪，不。嗯，是的，他们……我的意思是，从一开始，西班牙人就试图把新世界的人民描绘成食人者、鸡奸者。嗯，我还有什么？那些足以判他们死刑了，对吧？是的，我们总是把别人描绘成血腥的，而我们是神圣的、圣洁的，我们尊重和崇敬，巴拉巴拉。
Your book does a great job of saying that this is a reenactment of a reenactment of a reenactment of the processes of the universe. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, it's true that the sun won't, but it isn't because the sun's pissed off. And it's like, F you guys, I'm not going to rise today. It's like the sun just starved to death. The sun doesn't have the energy to be reborn in every morning unless we feed it. So, I mean, it's really a very sort of basic sort of agricultural or horticultural model of humans and nature interacting and we have to gift back to it in order for it to gift us um and you know contemporary not what speakers in mexico would argue that western culture isn't doing a very good job of that that climate change they're very much aware of it as dirt farmers, is the result of a gross imbalance, a failure to reciprocate, that give and take, give back, I give to you, you give to me.
巴拉巴拉。是的。是的，当然。好吧，这是一次美妙的谈话。我真的很感谢你的时间。嗯，
So that's really where all of that gory, horrid stuff is coming from, is this that we have to kiff back to keep the thing going. And there's probably a political element too, that we tend to punch down on ancient empires, bloodiness, or fixate on their bloody aspects to overlook where modern empires are extremely bloody. Yeah. We don't need to state the obvious. The elephant room. No good lord no um yeah they i mean from the get-go the spaniards were out to present new world people as cannibals um sodomites um i what else those were enough to condemn them to death right yeah we're always making other people out to be bloody and we're sacred and holy and we respect and revere like blah, blah,
我真希望我在三四年前第一次拿起你的书时就有一个播客。你想让我们说点关于下一本书的事吗？或者你有什么正在进行的作品想让我们链接到吗？
blah. Yeah. Yeah, for sure. Well, this has been a wonderful conversation with you. I really appreciate your time. Um,
我肯定会链接到可以购买这本书的地方。你有网站或任何其他网络存在，你想让我把人们引导到那里吗？不幸的是，我没有足够的数字技术来拥有一个网站。好的。我可以给你发一些关于阿兹特克文明的文章。所以现在我正在研究，嗯，你可能熟悉，嗯，头骨架（skull rack），对吧？
and I wish that I had been, had a podcast, you know, three, four years ago when I first picked up your, picked up your book, you want us to say anything about the next one or you got anything in the works that you want us to link to?
嗯，我正在论证，事实上，它是一个玉米地。它不是……我的意思是，标准的解释是它就像这种血腥的战利品展示。
I'll definitely link to where the book can be purchased you have a website or any other kind of web presence where you'd like me to direct people unfortunately i'm not digital savvy enough to have a website okay um i can send you some articles to some articles on an ethics so right now i'm working on, well, you're probably familiar with, well, the skull rack, right?
它在那里是为了恐吓每个人：“哦，我们阿兹特克人是坏蛋，看看我们积累了多少头骨。”根本不是那样。我的意思是，它可能对某些人有那种效果，但这只是因为事物本身具有内在的力量，而且它之所以强大，是因为那些头骨被构想为玉米粒。所以整个东西基本上是一个宇宙的“米尔帕”（milpa，玉米地），是这个仪式区、特诺奇蒂特兰中心所有正在进行的过程的最后阶段。那些是即将被重新播种以再生自然的种子。正在写一本书，论证我手头的事情太多了。抄本中的图像，
Well, I'm arguing that in fact, it's a, it's a Mays field. And that it's not, I mean, the standard interpretation is going to be that it's like this gory trophy display.
像这样的书，这些实际上是活的。它们不仅仅是绘画的呈现、描绘、符号或图片，它们是活生生的存在。那个知道自己在做什么的人与这些互动，这是一个神谕装置。你服用必要的精神药物，佩奥特（peyote），奥洛利（Olo Olo Lee）——我从来没读准这个词——曼陀罗（Jimson Weed），嗯，
It's there to like intimidate everybody oh we aztecs are bad mofos look at all these heads we've accumulated and it's not that at all i mean it may have that effect on some people but it's only because the thing itself is inherently powerful and it's powerful because those skulls are conceived as maze kernels and so the whole thing is basically a cosmic milpa and then the end stage of all the processes going on in this the ceremonial precinct this the center of the of chinoche titlan um and those are seeds about to be reseeded to regenerate nature. Working on a book which argues that I got too many things going on. Images in the codices,
你可以和这些人交谈。所以它们不是……这是当雕像死亡时它们变成艺术的另一个例子。
these books like this, that these are in fact alive. They're not just painted representations or depictions or symbols or pictures they are living beings and that person who knows what they're doing interacts with these it's this is an oracular device you take the requisite psychotropic substance peyote um ulu ulu i never um Olo Olo Lee I never pronounce this word Jimson Weed um
当这些死亡时，它们变成了艺术史学家的图像。嗯，这就是很多现代学术研究的感觉。洞穴
and you can talk with these people so they're not this is another example of when statues die they become art
绘画在史前时期会被使用，火使你画的动物或萨满仪式变得生动。有时也许你会找到正确的东西，处于迷幻药的影响下。是的。你去和它们交谈。那么那是在牛皮纸上还是在墙上？
this when these die they become images for art historians well and that's what a lot of modern scholarship feels like cave
你是说你会打开书，服用曼陀罗，然后你就会看到。不，你一次看一页。嗯，牛皮纸，它有时在纸上。有时在鹿皮上。是的。而且，图片是活的。只是在你服用正确的物质之前，它不会和你说话。
paintings would have been used for prehistorically that the fire animates the animal you paint or the shaman ritual. And sometimes maybe you find the right thing to be a little under the influence of a psychedelic. Yep. You go and you talk to them. So would that be on vellum or on the wall?
是的。而且，是的，你必须准备好自己。不是任何人都能走进去开始交谈。你必须受过训练，你必须经历各种我们称之为仪式的过程，比如禁欲、性禁欲、禁食，也许是自我放血，各种他们会描述为值得或配得上对话的方式。你必须让自己配得上与那一页上的神灵交谈。然后你服用相关的致幻剂，你就可以进行，这是一次神谕对话。你通常和他们交谈，对吧？
You're saying that you would open the book and take in the gypsum weed and you would see. No, you go to one page at a time. Yeah. Um, and vellum it's on, sometimes it's on paper. Sometimes it's on deer skin. Yeah. And the, and the, the, the picture is alive. It just isn't going to talk to you until you take the right substance.
这些被用于，你知道，你想去打仗，进行军事远征，商业远征，想结婚。你去找我们所谓的占卜师，说：“看看它。什么时候是做这件事的好时机？今天是个好时机吗？”所以你和那个人交谈，然后他做所有这些事情并与这些人物交谈。他们说：“不，今天不是个好日子。”
Yeah. And yeah, you got to prepare yourself. Not anybody can walk in and start talking. You to be trained you have to know you have to go through various sorts of what we would rituals like abstinence um sexual abstinence fasting perhaps self-bloodletting various ways in which they would describe as deserving or meriting conversation. You have to make yourself worthy of talking with the gods on that page. And then you take the relevant entheogen and you can have, and it's an oracular conversation. You talk to them typically,
是的。而且你必须做好准备。不是任何人走进去就能开始对话。你必须经过训练，必须经历各种我们称之为仪式的过程，比如禁欲、性禁欲、禁食，或许还有自残，通过各种方式来证明你有资格或值得进行这种对话。你必须让自己变得配得上与神灵交流。然后你服用相关的致幻剂，就可以进行神谕式的对话。你通常会与他们交谈，
right? These were used for, you know, you're going to want to go to war, go on a military expedition, a mercantile expedition, want to get married. You go to what we call diviner and say, look at it. When's a good time to do that? Was today a good time to do that? And so you talk to that person and he then does all of those things and talks to these persons. They say, nah, it's not a very good day.
对吧？这些仪式通常用于，比如你想发动战争、进行军事远征、商业远征，或者想要结婚时。你会去找我们所说的占卜师，问他们：看看这个，什么时候是做这件事的好时机？今天是个好日子吗？于是你与那个人交谈，他会完成所有这些仪式并与那些神灵沟通。他们会说，不，今天不是个好日子。
Or if you want us to cooperate, you're going to have to gift a certain sort of things. So it's a matter of enlisting these other than human persons, enlisting them in your practical endeavors so that they're on your side, not sort of opposing you. Wow. So you have oh yeah gift them right so that they gift you back the cooperation you desire yeah but you're interacting with a vast series of processes almost like some people use tarot or something like that in order to get outside of yeah yeah i don't know a lot about tarol but different forces yeah i don't know i think a lot
或者如果你想让我们合作，你就必须赠送某种东西。所以这是一个争取这些非人类个体的问题，把它们争取到你的实际工作中，这样它们就会站在你这边，而不是反对你。哇。所以你有，哦，是的，赠送它们，对吧，这样它们就会回赠你所渴望的合作，是的，但你是在与一系列巨大的过程互动，就像有些人使用塔罗牌之类的东西，为了跳出自我，是的，是的，我对塔罗牌了解不多，但不同的力量，是的，我不知道，我想很多
of the a lot of the uh historic use and more so than we think about and then the modern use is not really to see the future to do divination it's just to understand yourself and your life as a series of forces and then get outside of your own head about that enough to get them on your side you know or yeah make them conscious of yeah depending on your languages yeah this isn't about divining the future this is about yeah figuring out who are the players today right that's that's a really beautiful uh description and i best of luck with your work we look forward to your work on ethics and also um the you know the the the living art.
很多，呃，历史上的用途，比我们想象的要多，而现代的用途并不是为了预见未来，进行占卜，它只是为了理解你自己和你的生活是一系列力量的集合，然后跳出你自己的思维定势，足以让它们站在你这边，你知道，或者，是的，让它们意识到，是的，取决于你的语言，是的，这不是关于占卜未来，这是关于，是的，弄清楚今天谁是参与者，对吧，那是一个非常美丽的描述，祝你的工作好运，我们期待你在伦理学方面的工作，还有，你知道，那个，那个，活着的艺术。
Yeah, living art. You got titles? You know what you're going to call them? How far along are you through that? Well, the Skolrak is something like, I guess I can't give it a Nahua name in a book because nobody will know what it is. Skolrak as, I can't even say Milpa. I'm going to have to say it's Cosmic Mazefield, something like that.
是的，活着的艺术。你有书名了吗？你知道你要叫它们什么吗？你进展到什么程度了？嗯，Skolrak 就像是，我想我不能在书里给它起一个纳瓦特尔语的名字，因为没人知道那是什么。Skolrak，我甚至不能说 Milpa。我得说它是宇宙迷宫场，类似这样的名字。
The one is Conversing with Time, Aztec. Forget my, I've got a title, I don't know. All right. Well, good luck. I'll never look at a corn kernel, the same again. Okay, well, and if you ever, when those come out or when you, when you got a date on that,
一个是《与时间对话，阿兹特克》。忘了我的，我有一个标题，我不知道。好吧。好吧，祝你好运。我再也不会用同样的眼光看玉米粒了。好的，好吧，如果你们什么时候，当那些书出版的时候，或者当你们，当你们确定了日期的时候，
if you ever want to come back and promote something in a year or so, you know, please, please send me an email. Okay. I'll let you know if I ever get down to Alabama. Eclipse in a minute In a time Occupied in a minute There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你一年左右想回来宣传什么东西，你知道，请，请给我发封邮件。好的。如果我哪天去阿拉巴马州，我会让你知道的。一分钟内日食，在一段时间内，一分钟内被占据。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。